ok on va voir où vous en êtes mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire une hardy view
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment là
ce que je vais faire ce soir les cfd
naftogaz avec
le matin quand vous vous regardez dans
la glace vous pensez à quoi c'est qui
celui-là
sommes
pas faire les mêmes erreurs que dans le
passé mais que souhaite mais parce que
ce qui me concerne il faut toujours que
je travaille là dessus on peut retomber
aux chutes et est-ce qu'avec les
opérations quand vous vous regardez vous
vous reconnaissez ce que vous êtes
habitué à ce changement physique
je ne vois pas vraiment ce qu'ils ont
fait est bien ce que les entrées une
petite partie de mon oreille
hrw a sonné mon nez car
votre plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
là qu'elle mais
j'ai compris la blague j'ai compris
beaucoup d'annoncés laquelle
ça vous regarde pas
quand est-ce que vous avez pleuré pour
la dernière fois
david
dans ma chambre d'avis il a dû venir me
tenir par la main vous étiez triste
j'étais terrorisée pourquoi
je me suis bien amusé ici ça me plaît
ici
cette semaine sur mon mieux et ça fait
pas mal d'années
et son adresse
et ça m'a rappelé beaucoup de choses se
comprend vous seriez quoi en vous milk
et si vous aviez une baguette magique
dure question
en moi même
mais moi
j'aimerais apprendre à être seul sans
avoir besoin d'autrui ça ce serait bien
je pourrais rester dans ma chambre
j'avais sortir et être à l'aise
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
de chaînes et vous la luxure agneaux
fait la luxure que pourriez-vous dire de
plus négatif sur vous
j'ai des difficultés à communiquer avec
ma mère si votre vie était art fair milk
et qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
aux avenues les 11 premières années
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus mal
probablement lorsque ma femme m'a quitté
j'en avais honte
aujourd'hui qui avez vous le plus envie
d'épater dans la vie
pour brigode dieu
que feriez vous s'il vous restait 24
heures à vivre chaque fois que bref
baiser ma femme un appareil
mais
quelle est la dernière personne que vous
ayez envie de tuer toi si tu insistes
parce que lorsque je discute de ça avec
un traître il m'a ordonné de prier à la
vierge marie et il m'a dit qu'il fallait
pas le faire d'accord
je n'ai pas le faire de toute façon
j'allais envoyer mes potes mais j'avais
déjà pensé au suicide
d'un cadre non je suis catholique je
n'ai pas le droit de me suicider et vous
vous avez ce que je prenais beaucoup de
drogue donc à un moment je voulais me
suicider et puis je vais pas fait aussi
parce que je pense que c'est pas bien
parce que je suis catholique aussi comme
vous
c'est tout ce qu'ils se droguent les
catholiques 1,5 c fouet
seller the sticks les transitions qu'est
ce que la vie vous a appris
à ne pas faire deux fois les mêmes
erreurs
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
sans souffrance vous voulez être
enterrés ou incinérés
makolo sais je ne réponds pas faut
commander maintenant par un procès des
rations il ya 20 minutes d'attentes
dr de renom
hockey pouvait mentir et maintenant on
l'a déjà enterré tellement de fois lui
toute façon mickey est ce que vous avez
menti pendant cette interview hier
soir mais sauf que je fume un vous
regretter d'être venu là ouais pourquoi
dans ma chambre certes seuls je suis
très content de vous revoir et je vous
trouve beaucoup mieux que la première
fois que je vous ai vu en 87 vous êtes
beaucoup plus sympathique à l'époque
j'étais un peu bad boy un peu casse-cou
quoi j'aurais pas dit ça à l'époque dans
les programmes pilotes et un merci thank
you very much et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inler 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu